- Hi, everybody.
I'm Maurice Samuels, the Director
of the Yale Program for
the Study of Antisemitism,
and it's my great pleasure
to welcome you here today
to our Benjamin and Barbara
Zucker Lecture Series,
the first one of 2022.
Please make sure to sign up
for the YPSA mailing
list on the YPSA website.
We have a lot of great talks
planned for this semester.
So, today's speaker, Gregory Jones-Katz
is an American historian based
at the Chinese University
of Hong Kong, Shenzhen.
He earned his PhD from the
University of Wisconsin-Madison.
Greg works in the fields
of American intellectual
and cultural history, the
history of higher education,
and the global history of the humanities.
His first book "Deconstruction:
An American Institution"
was published in 2021, so just recently,
with the University of Chicago Press.
Greg's scholarly work has also appeared
in "History and Theory,"
"Analyse & Kritik,"
"Rethinking History" and
"Modern Intellectual History."
He's committed to public
facing scholarship
and has written for the Los
Angeles Review of Books,
the Chronicle of Higher Education
and other mainstream outlets.
So just a word about how
things are gonna work today,
Greg will speak for about 35 minutes.
Then we'll open it up for
questions from the audience.
Please submit your questions
using the Q&A feature
at the bottom of your screen.
The chat function is
disabled and I can't see you.
So I won't know if you raise your hand,
but I will ask questions that you submit
using the Q & A function.
We'll end promptly at 6:00 PM.
Greg's title today is
"Challenging Humanism:
"Jews, Theory and Yale
During the Closing Decades
of the 20th Century."
So please join me in welcoming Greg.
Come on.
Terrific, hi.
Okay, I'm gonna mute myself
now and you can take it away.
- Thank you.
Thank you, Maurice, for
inviting me tonight for my talk,
thank you to the Yale Program
for the Study of Antisemitism"
and thank you to everybody in attendance.
I'm going to be speaking tonight
about how Jews deployed theory at Yale.
This paper is derived
from a forthcoming article
in the journals "Jewish Social Studies,"
and it's part of an evolving
and larger study on the age of theory,
its production, consumption
and dissemination.
Informed of changes at Yale University,
and across American higher education,
then decentering the white male
and Christian European perspective,
pioneering Jews in the
late 1960s and 1970s
first reworked philosophical principles
of literary scholarship, and
then helped inaugurate an array
of curricular and intellectual changes.
With their anti-humanist,
often de-Christianizing work,
Jews at Yale theorized and while doing so,
also enlarged the purview
of humanities programs
and aided the establishment
of various departments
and fields of study.
This story is important
for several historiographical reasons.
Dan Oren, in 1985, provided a rich history
of how Jews strove to,
quote, "Join the club."
Building on Oren's
study, this talk explores
the intellectual consequences
of part of this movement.
This talk also explores how
Jews' curricular expansions
in the 1970s contributed
to what David Hollinger
has described as the
desacralization of academic culture.
Finally, I aim to illuminate
how Jews' deployments of theory
shaped humanistic tenants then informed
the Americanization of the Holocaust,
a process through which the
Holocaust was established
as a key reference point in
American culture and became
a central event of modern
American Jewish history.
By the mid 20th century, a
Christian Protestant culture
and norms was entrenched
in American universities.
From the 1970s and the 1980s,
Jews at Yale developed theory
from this social standpoint of exclusion
as a tool to challenge the existing order.
"Theory," Gerald Graff has observed,
"is what erupts when what
was once silently agreed to
"in a community becomes disputed,
"forcing its members to formulate
and defend assumptions."
Theory here, in this talk,
denotes that Jews questioned
and then reformulated about
humanism, but not just making
the explicit of
assumptions about humanism.
Theory is also a way
of interacting with it,
which produces new knowledge
and does not conserve traditions.
As such, Jews' challenges
of humanism at Yale
by using theory were anti-humanist,
though these challenges
generated knowledge
that reformed established
anti-humanist traditions.
This project was sometimes
thus an interpretive mode.
And sometimes, a mood
emanating from exclusion
and the marginalization as Jews.
By the mid 1960s, Western
intellectuals were exposing
the idea of universal man to be part
of Christian European ideology.
While authors pondered this crisis of man,
Geoffrey Hartman, who many
here have, perhaps, heard of,
and some here worked with,
I had the honor of spending
several afternoons talking to
him about his life and work,
while pondering this crisis of man,
Geoffrey Hartman explored the humanism
espoused in poetry and prose.
A half of century later,
his death in 1916 was widely observed.
It was noted Hartman's
birth in Frankfurt, Germany,
on August 11th, 1929, how he was sent
on Kindertransport by his
family to England in 1939,
how he was reunited with his mother
in New York City in 1946,
eventually attending Yale
where he was a faculty
member for four decades.
Hartman, quote, "Took
in the romantic poets,
"Judaic sacred texts, Holocaust studies,
"deconstruction, the workings of memory,
"even the very function
of criticism itself."
But looking back on his
career in the early 2000s,
Hartman observed, quote,
"I suspect I am, at heart, an essayist,
"always finding something
"of basic human and social interest."
The circumstances for this kind of work
were far from propitious.
At the end of the 19th
century, Jews were excluded
from English departments,
whose members often thought
themselves as defenders of,
quote-unquote, "civilization."
With the study of English literature,
as a way to inculcate culture, that is,
Anglo-Saxon Christianity.
Antisemitism remained rampant
during the interwar years,
but its decline in
explicitness after World War II
helped open opportunities for Jewish men.
Jews at Yale did not fare well.
True, since the university's
establishment in 1701,
Hebrew was required and from the 1800s,
Jews attended and worked there.
Hartman was not the first tenured Jew
in Yale's English department,
though the university
did maintain a quote-unquote
"genteel resistance to Jews"
after the end of the second World War.
Three academic generations
would combat the exclusion
of quote-unquote "the
Jew" from humanist ideals.
This project's prospects
were initially unclear
when members of Yale English
aligned literary education
with the inculcation of Christian beliefs.
Before World War II,
Professor Chauncey Tinker,
quote, "summarily vetoed consideration"
of Jewish-American Lionel
Trilling for professorship.
Jews, Tinker decided, quote,
"lacked the cultural
and religious background
"necessary for the teaching
of English literature."
The inclusion of Jews in
Yale English was slow.
Impetus came from legislation such
as Connecticut anti-discrimination
laws in the 1960s
and the 1964 Civil Rights Act.
A more approximate cause for changes
came from Kingman Brewster who,
appointed president of
Yale of University in '63,
asked admission staff to remove
the last relics of
discrimination against Jews
and other minorities.
The transformation of
the student body started
with the university's
recruitment from public schools.
By the late 1960s, the
homogenous quote-unquote,
"Yale undergraduate experience" was over,
but that was all long way off
when Charles Feidelson, Jr.,
the first tenured Jewish
scholar in Yale English,
challenged in a '48 book,
"Narratives of American Literature"
that justified the self
in Puritan identities.
But it was Harold Bloom,
close friends with Hartman
and who become one of the most famous
American literary critics
who first directly,
while Yale English's second
tenured Jewish critic,
challenged the Christian man constructed
out of Yale literary formalism.
Born in 1930, Bloom was raised
in a Yiddish speaking
household in the Bronx.
After receiving his undergraduate degree
from Cornell in '51, the
self-proclaimed street fighter
earned his PhD in Yale English in 1955.
Bloom called the department quote,
"an Anglo-Catholic nightmare.
"I walked out of a
lecture," he once wrote,
"by Tinker soon after it began,
"because it devoted
itself to the assertion
"that John Milton's poem, in every way,
"transcended the barbaric Hebrew text."
Bloom responded and his subversions
of Yale New Critics' work
were part of a movement
by Jewish scholars who seemed
to read their own situation
into the romantic
sympathies with outcasts,
exiles, and outsiders.
In Shelley's "Myth
Making," published in '59,
Bloom embraced Jewish
philosopher Martin Buber's
I-Thou concept of relationships to trace
the mythopoetic power of
Percy Shelley's poems.
Buber provided a foundation
for Jewish humanism
that countered the prevailing
Anglo-Christian humanism.
This alternative stressed how all, quote,
"philosophical, naturalistic,
humanistic ethics
"are inadequate, that
Jewish religious texts offer
"a more compelling basis
for ethical conduct."
Entering Yale's Comparative
Literature doctoral program
in the early 1950s, Geoffrey
Hartman similarly aimed
to antithetically navigate Yale formalism
and its Christian culture.
The measure Hartman judged
Yale English as possessing
a quote, "severe evangelical atmosphere."
Coming up through comp lit,
comparative literature,
and interested in European poetics,
Hartman appreciated Yale
New Criticism as quote,
"something small within
a much larger pedagogical
"and cultural enterprise."
His graduate education instilled
students with the belief
in the harmony of
European humanist culture
and the need to quote, "affirm
its literary inheritance."
In "The Unmediated
Vision," published in 1954,
Hartman read passages from
European poets to show that
a, quote, "common striving
for a poetry which mediated
"between its readers
and direct experience"
was a modern development
in literary history,
one that Yale's New Critics ignored.
But the Christian inflected
song remained the same
when he started teaching at Yale in 1955,
with restrictions on the number
of Jewish students enforced
under an admissions quota and excluding
one secular philosopher,
no tenured Jewish teachers
in the school's humanities departments.
Hartman's next book rethought
parameters of humanism.
In that short 1960 text, Hartman argued
that French writer, Andre Maurois, quote,
"Novel show that he was one
of the first to consider art
"and the heritage of Western
culture as very special weapons
"in an era of ideological warfare."
Maurois' aim was to, quote,
"reconstruct faith in humanism
"lost because humanistic
philosophies," quote,
"failed to produce politically
effective men of action."
For Hartman, the key
to reconstructing faith
in the political and intellectual
foundations of humanism
is a new kind of quote, "liberal hero,"
an intellectual or artist
capable of political action
to preserve man's free access
to his cultural heritage,
but also capable of withdrawal from action
when this end is achieved.
Hartman's investment in revised humanism
was then displaced to various outlets.
After denial of tenure at Yale in '61,
he assumed professorship
at the University of Iowa,
but when, in 1967,
Hartman returned to Yale
for a joint appointment in
the English and Comp Lit,
he returned to a school more
ready for confrontations
with Christian metaphysics.
While aiming to seize authority
from his literary critical forefathers,
Bloom himself offered
only clues about his aims,
as in the revised 1970
preface to his 1961 book,
"The Visionary Company."
There, Bloom implicitly
connects Jewish traditions
with the radical Miltonic,
romantic Protestant literary
tradition by showing
the latter's reverence for the
former's Biblical prophecy.
Bloom's romantics articulated, quote,
"A way of seeing and of
living a more human life."
Romantic poetry quote,
"either liberated man
"from his fallen condition
or more compellingly,
"made him see that this condition
"as an unimaginative fiction."
Hopeful, restorative and
subversive of his Yale
New Critical fathers
were Bloom's romantics,
a group who followed
in the poetic footsteps
of the Jewish prophets.
Retirements or deaths during
the first half of the 1970s
of Yale English's senior
members encouraged scholars
to contest literary humanism.
The challenges that emerged
in Yale English included Jews
who rose to senior positions,
including Hartman and Bloom,
and of junior rank.
Leslie Brisman argued in his
first book, published in 1973,
quote, "that the romantic
fascination with John Milton
"is a matter of choice,"
rather than as Bloom had it,
"anxious obligation."
Howard Felperin extended
deconstructionist theories
to the study of Shakespeare in 1972.
These pioneering Jews'
rewritings dovetailed
with Jews' theoretical
work to revise humanism
and were part of a larger
post-60s burst of approaches
that subverted the normativity
of knowledge and culture.
Bloom used theory to blaze
a quite heterodox path.
"An Anxiety of Influence,"
published in 1973,
Bloom developed an
Nietzschinized Freudian theory,
using it to show that
a great poet refracted
of revered precursors verse
TS Elliot argued that
great poets achieved access
to the literary tradition by
honoring their antecedents,
via quote, "a continual self-sacrifice,
"a continual extinction of personality,"
but Bloom's strong poets freed
their own artistic voices
by misreading and concealing
their debts to their ancestors.
Quote, "The history of
fruitful poetic influence
"is a history of anxiety
and self saving caricature
"of distortion, a perverse,
willful revisionism."
In Bloom's psychopoetic
universe, literary history
is a sequence of courteous revision was
but a naive humanist fantasy.
While Bloom's
de-Christianizing contribution
was a personal vendetta of sorts,
Hartman's assumed a
more community oriented
and explicitly Jewish direction.
After budget crunches of
the early 1970s and amidst
the destabilizing attacks
on the Christian identity
that grounded the identity
of older scholars,
Yale's humanists felt
their community in tatters.
A response to this grim
situation had come in the form
of a council in '73,
which Hartman chaired,
that addressed the
fragmentation of community.
Yet hopes springs eternal in Yale English,
and discerning onlookers
saw a critical group emerge,
with Hartman rising to
senior rank in Yale English.
Bloom's revisionist theories crystallized
in "Kabbalah and Criticism" in 1975,
a text from 1975 derived
from his university-wide
delivered DeVane Lectures at Yale.
While most Jews spoke
cautiously about their origins
in the 1960s and '70s,
here was the first critic
in the English tradition, a
half decade before the rise
of the new Christian
right, and on the heels
of the 1973 Arab-Israeli
war, not simply asserting
his Jewish identity, but speculating
that a mystical Jewish tradition rested
at the heart of Western culture.
Bloom theorized that the medieval systems
of Kabbalists Moses Cordovero
and Kabbalist Isaac Luria
showed that all great post-Miltonic poems
were determined by the
anxiety of influence
and followed patterns
laid down by the rabbis.
Yale critic W.K. Wimsatt
famously equated the works;
interformal harmony with a Christian moral
and aesthetic worth.
Bloom, though, decreed
poems obtained the illusions
of metaphysical presence, unity, form,
or even meaning from other poems.
"Student gossip," undergraduates wrote,
wrote that Bloom's
DeVane series represents
his attempts to defy
the New Critics at Yale.
Yale's 1977 offer of its
presidency to then Dean at Harvard,
Henry Rosovsky, symbolized
how far the school had come.
The mainstreaming of Jews,
like women and other minorities
into Yale's humanities
departments also involved
a countervailing force
against discrimination,
a merit-based academic culture.
To keep pace with peer
institutions, Yale turned to more
quote-unquote, "objective criteria
"for appointment and rewards,"
to the benefit of excluded
demographic groups.
Jews' uses of theory at Yale intersected
with the diversification of the faculty
and student population.
Around the same time as
the religious right gained
in prominence, and after
the 1970s resurgence
in the academic study of
Judaism, a growing number of Jews
earned senior faculty rank status,
the humanities departments at Yale became
invested in religious discourse
and radicalized practices of Judaism.
Hartman's interest
intersected with the push
among Yale faculty, begun in 1978,
to refurbish the school's
Judaic Studies program.
The efforts resulted in the establishment
of an undergraduate major in 1980.
The prominence of Yale's
Department of Religious Studies,
faculty argue, meant that
the university was quote,
"obliged to set the pace for effective
"and responsible graduate
study in the neglected area."
The subsequently founded
Judaic Studies program
was to pursue humanist goals as quote,
"The Jewish experience," a proposal reads,
"is coterminous in space
and time with the experience
"of Western man in general."
Hartman was appointed co-chairman
of Judaic Studies in early 1981.
He thought it was a
quote, "variant of opening
"the literary cannon
to a learning tradition
"as old as Rome and Athens."
Yale's Judaic Studies
programs was initiated
when anti-humanist theories were descended
in the American academy
while Jews used theory
to revised humanist aims.
Associated with the development drive
for Judaic Studies was the
funding of an archive at Yale
to house the Holocaust
Survivors' Film Project.
The project would be institutionalized
by way of psychoanalytic
theories, but it emerged in part
out of work undertaken
during the mid-1970s
by the New Haven Jewish
community, which in 1977,
completed a Holocaust monument,
America's first on
public land in New Haven.
The nationwide Holocaust Memorial culture
constructed through
editorials, newspaper articles
and correspondence in the
immediate postwar period
had thus begun to shift
to a different mode of public remembrance.
New Haven's Holocaust Monument
exemplifies this change.
In the 1960s, the American
public's attention
was only infrequently drawn
to the Jewish community
of Holocaust survivors.
TV miniseries "Holocaust,"
was the first major TV event
though, it upset survivors who believed
it massified and
under-theorized representations
of the Holocaust risked
establishing a moral paradigm
more exploitative than educational.
Such a (indistinct) view
of televised portrayals
of the Holocaust informed
a 1979 discussion
on Channel 8 in New Haven of a documentary
about the New Haven Holocaust Memorial.
Local filmmaker, Laurel
Vlock invited Dori Laub,
a child survivor and New Haven
psychiatrist, to participate.
They speculated that
survivors might be prepared
to document the stories.
Vlock and Laub began filming four stories.
And then the two realized
the impact the recordings
would have if shared widely.
An early 1980 proposal to garner support
for the newly established
Holocaust Survivals Film Project
also explained the urgency
behind the recording endeavor.
Quote, "The overriding
consensus of Jews everywhere
"is that we must never
forget what happened,
"that our children must be taught again
"and again, to remember the Holocaust,
"even though they were not
alive during the dreadful era
"of Nazi Germany, nevertheless,
not enough is being done
"to record the living
memory of those years.
"Every survivor who dies without
leaving a meaningful record
"of his or her experience
in the Holocaust,
"a record which can be seen
and heard and studied by Jew
"and non-Jew alike for all time to come
"constitutes an
immeasurable historical loss
"for which we can no longer afford."
Situating survivor
testimony as antithetical
to common representations of the Holocaust
and in distinction to
anti-humanist discourses
circulating in humanities departments,
a public act of remembrance was felt
to be of vital importance.
The HSFP's revised humanist
ambitions were stressed
during the official
launching on June 28th, 1979
at a press conference in New Haven
that included New Haven mayor,
local Jewish and Christian clergy,
leaders of the New
Haven Jewish Federation,
a representative of the planned
United States Holocaust Memorial Museum.
The President's Commission
on the Holocaust
hailed the project.
Elie Wiesel, the chair of
the President's Commission,
highlighted the cultural link
between the Jewish community and humanity.
Quote, "The most vital lesson to be drawn
"is that Auschwitz was possible
"because the enemy of the
Jewish people in a mankind,
"and it is always the same enemy,
"succeeded in splinting human society,
"nation against nation,
Christian against Jew,
"young against old."
The recording of testimonies
became an international effort.
When the HSFP found a home at Yale,
in part due to Geoffrey Hartman,
its theoretical framework was fleshed out.
Having evaded the direct
impact of the Holocaust,
Hartman felt a responsibility
to help give voice to survivors.
One of the first four Holocaust survivors
Dori Laub interviewed was
Geoffrey's wife, Renee,
who in 1944, was sent to Bergen-Belsen.
Hartman's interest was
surely also stirred by Laub,
whose theoretical manner of approaching
the video tape project intersected
with Hartman's incorporations
throughout the 1970s
of psychoanalytic theories to develop
a distinct psycholinguistics
that addressed
the link between words and psychic wounds.
Laub theorized that trauma
survivors could mend life
only when trauma was represented.
In the HSFP, Laub's approach,
a clear theoretical
position that responded
to the visual age that
Hartman had written about,
required listeners to follow the lead
of self-aware survivors.
Fulfilling the project's goal
would contribute to scholarship as well.
Quote, "Psychoanalytic
work done in survivors,"
reviewers of a funding application read,
"is rather scarce when the
magnitude of the phenomenon
"is taken into account and
the work done was never part
"of a large systematic study."
Despite the manifest
historical, pedagogical
and scholarly significance,
the larger academic community
only took notice of the HSFP after members
of the Yale community sanctioned
the undertaking in 1981.
While co-chairman of Yale's
new Judaic Studies department,
Hartman helped inaugurate
Yale's Fortunoff Video Archive
of Holocaust testimonies
on November 15th, 1982,
with the original tapes
formally deposited at Yale.
Peter Novic argued in 2000
that during the 1970s, quote,
"American Jews' anxiety
about Israel's security
"and their viewing Israel's situation
"within a Holocaust framework
"was the single greatest
catalyst of the centering
"of the Holocaust in American
Jewish consciousness."
An avenue for the positioning
was Yale's Fortunoff Archive,
and this archive was itself a
result of grassroots efforts
in New Haven and Jews'
uses of theory to create
a Jewish humanist moment
at Yale that altered
and created intellectual spaces for Jews
and Jewish history and culture.
President Reagan habitually invoked,
invoked Judeo-Christian values as elements
in the struggle against
communism and/or the glue
that held America together.
For different purposes, editors
of the 1985 inaugural issue
of "Orim," a Jewish journal at Yale,
assessed the Jewish
community's Yale existence.
Quote, "When a great
university," they wrote,
"becomes an important
center of Jewish learning,
"the event is in itself a
profound commentary on the nature
"of the American Jewish experience today."
Great universities were now institutions
where the once virtual
identification of humanism
with Christian culture had been shattered
with Jewish experiences and religious
and poetic traditions embraced.
Yale president A. Bartlett Giamatti,
former professor of
Renaissance Literature,
threw his support behind the archive,
while Jewish, cultural and
religious life cohered at Yale.
Yale Hillel and Young Israel
House were working together.
Reflecting the new
unity, Orim's commentary
on the link between the contemporary
and earlier American Jewish experience
also included a section on Midrash,
the classical rabbinic tradition.
Quote, "Our grandfathers and
fathers had their stories
"of affliction, hope, escape, labor,
"but above all, of attachment
to Talmud and Midrash."
"Orim" did not turn to
these quote-unquote,
"resonating words" simply to
interpret the past, however.
Quote, "Even in the new
tales of visions and triumph
"in alien worlds, the ancient word threads
"could still be discerned with
which a God obsessed people
"had tried unendingly to
lend form and substance
"to the intuitions of
his collective soul."
Speculation on how ancient
word threads shaped
the modern Jewish-American
experience was part
of academics' theorization
going on then about rhetoric,
that itself, due in part to the popularity
of what is known as French theory.
American literary critics sympathized
with the rabbinic theories
of language, because they too
cared for quote, "every element
of scripture as meaningful."
By the early 1980s, the quote,
"Midrash theory connection"
had become a hot topic
in literary studies.
Contributing to a project
on literature and Midrash
at the Hebrew University of Jerusalem,
Hartman applied Midrashic
deconstructive theories
to the textual fault lines
of Jacob's wrestling with the angel.
Scratched underneath the names listed
on Orim's Yale Faculty Advisory Board
reveals the scope of Jews
uses of Midrashic theory
to advance their humanism.
The board included poet, John Hollander.
In the '80s, Hollander
theorized that poetry, quote,
"In the West was like the
rabbinic textual tradition."
In 1988 article, he wrote, quote,
"All poetry is unofficial Midrash.
"At the very beginning of the
Western literary tradition
"were Homer and Torah,
but the great poetry
"that followed them became
part of the canon as well."
Alan Goodman had in 1972 sought answers
as to why there were not more
major American Jewish poets
in the English literary tradition.
While Hollinger's colleague, Bloom,
believed in the early 1970s
that American Jewish poetry
had yet to truly mature, he, in 1988,
read Hollander's "Spectral
Emanations" collection from 1978
as quote, "Somber American
Jewish mythmaking,
"founded on the metaphor of menorah."
For Bloom, this poetry resolved
the Jewish-American
contradiction by combining
a sacred strain and a late
romantic worldly passion.
And yet, some at Yale English
members still found it curious
that stars in the
department were interested
in Jewish modes of reading.
In 1986, a New York Times
writer quoted a lapsed Baptist
in Yale English who thought it odd that,
in his department, there were, quote,
"Jews who have found
medieval Midrash and Kabbalah
"more or less compelling
modes of interpretation."
The manner of Jews' contributions
to the theoretical humanist movement
were nominally different in
the French department at Yale.
There, Shoshana Felman,
also on Orim's Faculty Advisory Board,
explored the connections
between Holocaust survivor
testimonies and French theory.
Felman received degrees
at the Hebrew University
of Jerusalem, and in 1970,
earned her PhD in French literature
at the University of Grenoble.
Felman then joined the French department
and in 1973 became its
first tenured woman and Jew.
In the late 1980s, she became
a member of a circle at Yale
comprised of Hartman, Dori
Laub, Cathy Carruth and others
formed around the concept of testimony.
Culminating the interdisciplinary work
in psychiatric theories that centered
on the Fortunoff Video Archive,
Felman labored with
Yale to produce in 1992,
a key text in the field of
traumatic mental health,
and a definitive work on testimony.
In it, Laub wrote about
his work as a psychoanalyst
with Holocaust survivors while Felman used
autobiographical accounts of
Holocaust and war survivors,
as well as art, literature,
and videos to explore the link
between trauma and pedagogy.
Holocaust survivor testimonies
have become touchstones
for TV representations of
the Holocaust in the 1980s,
but in the 1990s,
Felman's and others' work
helped secure the video
archive's reputation
by offering a theoretical complexity
and Jewish underpinnings that aided
the establishment of trauma studies.
By the mid 1990s, in fact,
Jewish literary critics
and scholars who used
theory to challenge humanism
had reached the pinnacle
of the profession.
As for this Jewish
movement's local effects,
the chauvinism in Yale English
was left to historians to explore,
while the de-Christianization
of literary studies there
interconnected with the
establishment of Jewish spaces.
In the 1980s and 1990s,
Yale's Judaic Studies program
exposed future leaders and clergy
to an appreciation of Jewish traditions.
Yale served as a path through
which Jews and Jewish texts
and culture was shown as
integral to the larger society.
When the third academic generation Jews
earned professorships and
positions across America,
becoming presidents of the
Modern Language Association,
directors and editors of literary
histories and anthologies,
Judaic Studies' cultural work--
(static crackling)
background that it helped construct.
One legacy linked to Jews'
deployments of theory at Yale,
witness and survivor's accounts recorded
for the Fortunoff Video Archive
for Holocaust testimonies,
contributed to making the
Holocaust a central reference
in American culture and
modern Jewish history.
Consider Lawrence
Langer's book, 1991 book,
"Holocaust Testimonies,"
which the 1995 issue
of the New York Times
Review of Books listed
as one of the century's
100 most important books.
Based on eight years of
studying oral testimonies
held in the Fortunoff Archive,
Langer's study theorized
that created, quote, "An
impromptu self in the camps
"in order to remain alive."
A 27-minute piece for
string quartet and tape,
Steve Reich's "Different Trains"
from 1995 creates melodies
from looped spoken phrases
from the Fortunoff Archive.
These phrases were all reminisces
about their radically
different experiences
during the second World War.
The piece won a 1990 Grammy award
in the classical music category.
In these ways and other,
the Fortunoff Video Archive
thus played a role in the
Americanization of the Holocaust.
When filmmaker Stephen Spielberg
and the Shoah Foundation prepared
to launch a more extensive
Holocaust testimony in the
mid-1990s, they sought the help
of Fortunoff Archive staff,
including Hartman, Dana Klein,
and Joanne Wiener Rudolf.
The video archive informs Spielberg's goal
to offer an education
and provide blueprints
for potential action about the Holocaust
and other genocides.
Providing an education
met a widely felt need
in multicultural America
for a common moral contract
of a broadly held ethical paradigm.
Historicizing how Jews
employed theory at Yale
to institute a revised
humanist movement and mood
helps in the understanding
of how the university
became a center of Jewish
and humanist learning.
This work can be seen as but
one chapter in the larger
branch of theory in the American academy,
a story of how Jews in
concert with feminist studies,
post-colonial studies, ethnic studies,
and other scholars helped decenter
the Christian European perspective.
Yet what remains certain
is that Yale's Jews,
who in mid-century felt
excluded from scholarship
and the profession, partook in an informal
collective intellectual enterprise
at once distinctive to the
situation in history of Jews
and Yale, and in some
ways, illustrative of Jews
and the increasing Jewish presence
in American arts and
humanities departments.
In addition to the de-Christianization
of literary studies
during the '60s and '70s,
Yale's humanist Jews'
uses of theory helped
create Jewish avenues
in the late '70s and '80s
for the public remembrance
of the Holocaust, influencing
modern American identity
and modern Jewish identity.
Uncovering a theoretical
path at Yale through which
the Holocaust rose to
prominence in scholarship
and in public awareness of
Jewish history and culture,
this history of Jews,
theory and Yale ultimately
might help illuminate
the constructive ways
in which it became foregrounded.
Thank you all for listening.
And I look forward to
hearing your questions.
Thank you.
- Okay.
Thank you, Greg.
I think we have a lot to talk about.
That was a really interesting talk,
and there are a lot,
already a lot of questions
and just looking at the list
of people who are attending,
I think there are people who
were part of that history here.
So one thing just off,
to start, I was interested
and happy to hear you say
that the French department was,
I'm a professor of French,
and was a little bit different
from the English department.
I would say, that Felman was
not the first tenured Jew
in the French department.
Before her, there was Georges May,
who was a very important
figure on the Yale campus,
and who was Dean in 1968,
Dean of the college,
which was a very, and
Victor Brombert also,
I think, was before.
- I just wanted to-
- Yeah.
- So I meant woman.
- Oh, the first woman tenured.
Right, okay, the first, got it.
But it is interesting
that the French department
would've been more, open,
and I'm wondering like, I mean,
this is my own kind of interest here, but,
do you think that that's because
of a certain kind of
intellectual tradition in France
versus the United States,
is that a legacy of French universalism
being sort of theoretically
more open to Jews?
Or is it a sociological thing,
if there were just a lot
of Jews who studied French,
like George May and Brombert,
who were European refugees,
or maybe they weren't
even perceived as Jews,
as much as people in the English
department would've been,
they were just foreign, you know?
- So, well, I think that
it's the legacy, okay,
obviously there are many
factors that go into this,
but if I have to give an answer,
I would say that the legacy
in this case would be,
I imagine just that the
legacy or the culture
in Yale English developed,
has deep traditions in American culture.
And I think that you're right to emphasize
the French emphasis on universalism
and the emigre scholars as well.
I think were, perhaps, I mean,
you would know more about this,
perhaps more prominent in
French than in the cases
of Yale English, where those
scholars were, perhaps,
coming from Anglo-American,
like let's say an
Anglo-American pool, let's say.
And so, I think that
that lent and inculcated
a certain culture in the department.
At the very least, it created
a intellectual culture
that scholars such as Hartman
and Bloom were very aware of
and sensitive to, and
so, perhaps the cultures
were not as stark.
I mean, I would need to
do more work, however,
from the perspective of, let's say,
American Jews studying,
especially in this case,
the romanticism, right, in Yale English,
there's all this, it's all loaded
with these meanings,
implicit and explicit.
- Yeah, it makes me think
of a book that I really like
a lot, Jonathan Friedman's
book, "The Temple of Culture,"
where he talks about how,
the very idea of culture
in the Anglo-American
context was, we're thinking
about Matthew Arnold and
people like that is theorized,
as a kind of opposition to a Hebraicism,
and that is, there is
that current, I think,
within French culture too,
but it's maybe not the dominant one.
So okay, so one thing that I,
a question that immediately
leapt out at me, and I
see some of the people
in the audience, too,
in one of your pictures,
there was, of the French,
I think it was Lacan's lecture,
there's Paul De Man is in the picture,
and it seems like he's a kind
of key part of this story,
and wondering if you can
say a little bit more
about his role in this.
And how does that fit into your argument
about the kind of humanist,
contesting humanism,
where does his brand of deconstruction,
maybe just maybe tell us a little bit
for those who might not
know, who was De Man
and what was the scandal?
- So Paul De Man, a leading
figure in what is known
as literary deconstruction
or deconstruction in Comp Lit
and French at Yale, and
beginning in, I believe,
he was hired in 1970, but
he began teaching in '71
and until his death in '83, and then,
so his reputation of his
theory was essentially
the reputation, which in my opinion is,
well, the reputation is
that his literary theory
was explicitly anti-human
and nihilistic, almost,
very destructive of let's
say the core humanist values
that let's say college
is supposed to teach.
And in 1987, 4 years after his death,
it was discovered that he wrote
approximately 200 articles
when he was 20 and 21 years old in Europe.
He was a Belgian, so he
is a Belgian-American,
and two of them were, I would,
explicitly antisemitic, whereas
the vast majority of them
were culturally, at the
very least sympathetic
to the German dominant, the
Nazi dominance of Europe.
And this was very controversial.
He was very close friends
with both Harold Bloom
and Geoffrey Hartman, who had
their own different responses
to the controversy, but they were a part
of an intellectual cohort
at Yale that were pursuing
deconstructive theories, essentially.
Yeah.
- Okay, there are a few
questions I'm seeing
from the audience about
the concept of humanism
and anti-humanism.
Someone writes, "I'm
uncomfortable with the language
"of anti-humanism.
"It smacks of Heideggerian roots
"and can only be bad for the Jews.
"Discuss."
Someone else writes, and you
can do with this what you want,
"How did these Jewish scholars
in their intellectual movement
"engage with concurrent movements
"contesting Christian humanism at Yale,
"specifically women's studies
and African American studies?
"How would you characterize
the relationship
"between these movements?"
And then another one,
"Must we conjoin humanism to Christianity?
"Admittedly, it was so
conjoined at the Quattrocento,
"but humanism now despised by Christianity
"was the undergirding of
the scientific method.
"The age of theory contained
a good deal of reaction
"and posturing De Man, not
to mention obscurantism,"
someone wrote in.
- So these are great questions.
I'll just start at the
first one, which I believe
was about being uncomfortable
with the word anti-humanism,
I think was the question.
- Yeah.
- I would just argue,
I thought about this.
I see this moment with this paper,
and what I'm trying to talk
about as a dialectical in a way.
I see, at the end of their careers,
for example, Hartman and
Bloom are very comfortable
saying I'm humanist,
I'm a humanist, right?
Now, in the '70s, they are
labeled as anti-humanist,
but I see it as dialectical
in that some of the moves
that some of these scholars are making
are in the name of a humanism,
but they are critiquing
some of the assumptions
or implicit meanings
that are then loaded with
humanism as it was practiced
in the '50s, '60s, and '70s.
So I see it as historical in that sense,
and not like we could pick this work out
of its historical context
to say, oh, anti-humanist.
You know?
It was in the name of a humanism,
especially looking back on it,
but it was sometimes labeled
itself as anti-humanist.
But again, the dialectical,
these sort of movement,
I think, is important,
and I had one sentence
in the beginning of my
talk that I think kind
of alludes to this argument,
and then I sort of moved on.
So that's how I would answer that.
So these are humanists,
but they are attacking
the principles of humanism in
the name of a new humanism.
Now, the De Man case, I think
that's more complicated,
personally, I think that
that's, and I can't,
I feel uncomfortable talking about it
with this project that
I talked about today.
Whether he's an anti-humanist
for all time is a debatable,
is probably the case.
So, and then the second question,
I think was a Heidegger,
is that a question about Heidegger?
- Are there are Heideggerian connotations
to anti-humanist-
- So, Heidegger,
well, I mean, so speaking
of the two main figures
I looked at, Bloom and Hartman,
I mean, Bloom notoriously said,
very, very, very funny, but
also aggressive comments
about how much he did not like Heidegger
and all the Heideggerian critics
that were inspired by Heidegger,
even though he was very close friends,
Bloom was very close friends with Derrida
and all these other figures.
So is there something
suspiciously Heideggerian about?
I mean, think, (clears throat)
Heidegger does cast a
long, intellectual shadow
that whether, for example,
in the case of Bloom,
whether they agree with Heidegger or not,
they were still struggling and dealing
with what had been created in
the aftermath of Heidegger,
and also, of course,
Heidegger's complicity
with the Nazi regime and
what that all brings up
and very serious, very,
very serious issues.
So does it raise this Heidegger? Yes.
I mean, I think that it does.
I think in a larger study, this
would have to be addressed.
And yes.
- Okay.
Great.
So I wanna dig down a little bit deeper
in the question of the specificity
of Yale in your argument.
So like, why, how much of the, well,
I guess there are two
parts of the question,
like how much of your
story is specific to Yale
and how, if you could say
a little bit more about,
analogous kind of changes
going on in other universities,
even at other Ivys or
just other universities,
and then, why this happened at Yale?
You know, I was sensing a
kind of line of your argument
that a lot of it had to
do with the contingency
of certain personalities at Yale,
like just the presence
of Bloom and Hartman
and the force of their personalities.
But I wonder if there was also something
about Yale's own history
that maybe determined that,
or even its geography,
its place in New Haven.
I could see lots of potential answers, so.
- So basically, why Yale and and why,
how were other universities grappling
or not with these changes?
- Yeah.
- Well.
So a more...
I'll start with the 1970s.
I mean, Yale, and I did not
mention this in my talk,
Yale had their first cohort
of women undergraduates,
I believe admitted in 1969.
So, and then, they also instituted the,
I hope I get this right,
the first, oh gosh,
some of the first ethnic
studies departments
were also started at Yale.
So the there's this larger
moment, at least in '70s,
post-60s, let's say, okay?
Where some of the assumptions
that I alluded to,
the sort of white male
Christian image of humanism
were being decentered, okay?
Now, if you go back a little
further, in the '50s and '60s,
then you have the Yale English issue,
where these are sort
of by the, as you say,
the force of personalities
with Bloom and Hartman,
there, they're challenging
in their own way,
in a more local issue or more
localized confrontations.
Some rather indirect and oblique.
I mean, they didn't come out,
after they got their PhDs
and sort of challenged these
issues, but it wasn't until
the '70s that while those other changes
at Yale were happening.
Now there's also the issue
of Yale being, again,
I should have written this down,
I hope my memory doesn't fail me here,
but Yale is founded as a
seminary originally, right?
So, I mean, this goes
back hundreds of years.
So Yale has this much longer
history of being a seminary,
this religious background tied to, I mean,
sort of the New England,
let's say, culture.
So, and you have that,
that much longer history,
you have the '70s, that I
mentioned, you have Yale English,
the more local issue, and
then you also have the issue
of Yale in the postwar, after 1945,
as being one of the, and known as having
the best English department in the world.
This is like a phrase
people would throw around,
so to have the best English
department in the world,
combined in the '50s and '60s
with all these other issues,
right, you create this situation,
especially if you have, let's
say, these younger scholars,
such as Bloom and Hartman coming through,
who are Jewish, who are in
the best English department
in the world, all these
other issues percolating,
also, Yale, of course, in the 1970s,
becomes a center of deconstruction,
which was considered,
for better or for worse,
depending on your views,
the most advanced theory of, let's say,
a technique for reading literature.
So it becomes this focal
point of deconstruction
and theory, the most
advanced work being done
in the humanities, which
usually, at that point,
came through literature departments,
so you have all these factors
happening at the same time.
Some longer history,
some shorter histories
that I think contributed to this moment,
and I also, oh sorry.
- No, no, no, go ahead.
- As to other universities, well,
other universities don't have that,
at least quite in the same way,
the Ivys don't have that
combination of factors.
I mean, other Ivys such as
Dartmouth, went co-ed as well.
I believe Dartmouth was the
first, I could be wrong.
So there are these, but it's not quite,
it doesn't have all the other
factors that I mentioned.
Public universities is a different story.
You know, University of Wisconsin-Madison
developed a quite different relationship,
because of anti-discrimination
laws, is my understanding,
that were enforced at public universities,
whereas Yale being private,
I think it was a different situation.
I think, I would need to do
more work on that, to be honest.
- So let me throw out an
idea, which is that I wonder
whether the turn towards Holocaust studies
that you talk about in your talk,
by many of the deconstructionist critics,
that they make this turn
to Holocaust studies.
And you know, to go back to De Man,
I guess I've always sort
of read that as linked,
that it was this sort
of, the De Man affair,
this recognition that their colleague
had this kind of
complicity, you could argue,
and I feel some of those
tensions are very present
in Shoshana Felman's, in the
"Testimony" book, especially,
and that it's almost like a kind of,
I don't wanna say a making amends,
but there a kind of
like, or reconsideration
of the presence of history
and trying to figure out
a way to do that theoretically,
and that that Holocaust,
I mean, what do you think about it?
- Well, I mean, I think
you're absolutely correct.
I mean, well, not absolutely correct.
My view is, yes, with the
Felman "Testimony" book,
I think this is also true.
It's a sincere, rigorous
attempt to grapple
with exactly what you said,
this question of history
that De Man's theory had
completely bracketed, essentially,
for professional,
intellectual, personal reasons.
But I will say that, and you know,
yeah, many of his former
colleagues did that, as well,
after the De Man affair, in '87, however,
however, Hartman, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I was about to say,
Hartman began work on
his psycholinguistics,
he was working on that in 1970s,
and as I mentioned in the talk,
and he had pulled away
from what he called,
let's say, the Boa
deconstructors, by the late 1970s.
So there was already, as
someone just commented,
there was already a move
among a certain cohort
of deconstructionists
towards a way to sort of try
to reconcile, let's say,
put this in quotation marks,
anti-historical
deconstruction versus history.
That really came to
public notice, let's say,
in terms of publications
after the De Man affair.
So I think that's a bit of an illusion,
so Hartman's work goes back.
And yeah, so I think you're right,
nevertheless, I think that the view stands
that there is a grappling
that attempts to be.
- And you know, I wanted to say before,
right when I came on that just
to credit Geoffrey Hartman
with, really, the creation
of the antisemitism program
that we're, I mean, I think it would not,
he was instrumental in setting
up this program in 2011,
and it probably would not
have been created without him,
and that's a whole other story
that we can talk about privately.
But he was really, and you
know, we inherited a lot
of his library on books
about antisemitism.
So just wanted to acknowledge that.
So maybe, last question
in the remaining time,
and then, a few people have posed it,
and it occurred to me, too,
if you could say something
about the current campus dynamics,
and someone, one of the
people in the questions
put it very well that Jews used to be seen
as these kind of renegades,
kind of challenging accepted norms,
and now, arguably, are seen
as part of the establishment,
kind of just white,
basically, at Yale now.
And so, I don't know, can
you say something about that,
and kind of current campus dynamics?
Not at Yale, necessarily, but.
- So that's really tough for me to answer,
to be honest with you.
I'm not sure how to answer that,
and the reason why is
because I have lived in China
since 2016, and I think that,
I mean, I understand the question, but,
I think it's a great question,
how the switch from renegade
to, let's say, establishment,
or I'm not sure how you wanna put it, but,
when that happened.
Oh gosh, I'm really sorry.
- Yeah, no, no, no, I
mean, it's interesting-
- [Gregory] Great question.
- And you know, to kind
of think about the place
of Judaic Studies, one
of the kind of goals,
I think, of our program,
the antisemitism program,
is to inject questions
of antisemitism and Jews
into discussions about race on campus.
And so, and to try to think
about ways to do that.
Anyway, it's an interesting thing.
So can you just say, so are you, really,
last question, how are you
think about this project?
Are you seeing it develop as a book?
Is it like a group portrait?
Is it gonna be focused on Yale
or was that talk just for us
or how are you seeing it?
- No, I mean,
I have an idea for a project
about like global theory,
its production at various
sites in the United States,
and then its dissemination
abroad, and this would be,
this was a project that
really got me really thinking
about how and why that was happening,
and so, for example,
my definition of theory
at the beginning, trying to understand,
these Jews, one way of thinking about it
is they formalized the assumptions.
Right, they used, these are techniques
that formalized the ones,
the assumptions that existed
in the culture around them.
And whatever situation they were in,
whatever field they were in,
so I see this as part of a larger project,
but it won't be focused on Yale,
although I'm happy to continue.
These were great questions,
and happy to expand this,
but I guess we'll see.
- Okay, terrific.
Well thank you so much for
sharing your work with us,
and thank you to everyone in the audience,
and everyone who submitted questions,
and as I said, I encourage everybody to go
to the YPSA website and
sign up for our mailing list
and we have a lot of other
great programs set up
for this coming semester.
So thanks to Greg.
I will clap for everyone.
You can't hear all the
clapping, but it's there,
and see you all at another
event sometime soon.
- Thank you so much.